on se souvient de ces images houran
entièrement verrouillé et confiné entre
le 23 janvier et le 8 avril pour tenter
d'endiguer l'épidémie de covile 19
une fois ces mesures de restriction
levée face à la menace du virus les
autorités de la ville ont décidé de
dépister l'ensemble de la population
âgée de 6 ans et plus près de 10
millions de personnes testées entre le
14 mai et le 1er juin dernier
et c'est sur ces résultats de cette
campagne de dépistage que porte cette
étude publiée dans la prestigieuse revue
nature il y a quelques jours alors que
nous apprend cette étude chinoise
eh bien d'abord que plus aucun cas
positif symptomatique n'a été détectée
haouran et que seuls 300 cas
asymptomatiques ont été identifiés mais
surtout et c'est là le plus important
sur les 1160 14 cas contacts liés à ces
personnes asymptomatiques
aucune n'a été testé positif au sein
skov deux pas une seule
cela signifie plusieurs choses on peut
déjà constater la fin définitive de
l'épidémie haoran les auteurs de l'étude
rapporte d'ailleurs que deux mois après
cet immense campagne de dépistage
il n'y avait aucun nouveau cas confirmés
à travers toute la ville mais surtout
ces chiffres montrent que les
asymptomatiques ne propagent pas la
maladie par rapport aux patients
symptomatiques les personnes infectées
asymptomatiques ont généralement une
faible quantité de charge virale et une
courte durée d'excrétion virale ce qui
diminue le risque de transmission du
sart skov deux dans la présente étude la
culture du virus a été réalisé sur des
échantillons de cas positifs
asymptomatique et n'a trouvé aucun virus
ars cov de viable
tous les contacts étroits des cas
positifs asymptomatiques se sont révélés
négatifs
ce qui indique que les cas positifs
asymptomatiques détecté dans cette étude
était peu susceptible d'être infectieux
alors pour certains cette conclusion
n'est pas une surprise l'organisation
mondiale de la santé avait déjà déclaré
le 8 juin dernier que les transmissions
asymptomatiques étaient rares le docteur
anthony fauci immunologue et un temps
conseiller privilégié de donald trump
sur la crise sanitaire avait tenu des
propos similaires mais pour d'autres
cette étude vient contredire d'autres
publications
d'abord il faut noter que l' oms avait
déjà fait marche arrière concernant la
rareté des transmissions asymptomatiques
et l'organisation précise bien sûr son
site internet que les asymptomatiques
sont bel et bien contagieux et puis
l'étude chinoise publiée dans nature
fait elle même référence à plusieurs
publications antérieures qui conclut
elle que les asymptomatiques était bien
infectieux sans compter l étude publiée
le 22 septembre dernier dans la très
sérieuse revue thorax selon laquelle un
infecté asymptomatiques sur cinq aurait
une charge virale est égale à celle des
malades présentant des symptômes
alors peut être que les chiffres de
l'étude chinoises sont liées à l'état de
l'épidémie haouran déjà terminé fin mai
et qui donc n'aurait engendré que des
infections à faible charge virale c'est
une simple spéculation
l'étude chinoise ne le dit pas ni aucune
publication d'ailleurs mais quand bien
même les conclusions de l'étude chinoise
de nature's serait généralisable est ce
que cela aurait un effet sur les mesures
de restriction en france comme ailleurs
et bien pas sûr selon une méta étude
publiée dans plos medicine le 22
septembre dernier le taux d'à
symptomatique se situerait autour de 20%
des personnes infectées d'autres papiers
ont avancé des taux allant de 30 à 50%
une partie de la population non
négligeable pourrait donc quitter leur
confinement reste cependant toujours
ceux qui sont bien malades et donc
contagieux et d'ailleurs infectieux
avant même l'apparition d'éventuels
symptômes
en revanche si l'étude de nature's a
bien prouver définitivement quelque
chose c'est qu'avec 10 millions de
personnes testées en deux semaines la
campagne de dépistage des ouvrages
ridiculise les efforts des gouvernements
européens en la matière